Westworld teaser trailer from HBO oh
great job last world is a great movie I
saw the original twice when I was really
young my dad did not believe in
censoring me it was a nightmare of a
movie because it starts off fantastical
yeah then it turns into a horrible
experience yeah you know it's like
Jurassic Park
I saw West world in school we watched it
for like a genre film class I took and
so I imagine if I saw it when I was
younger boom well no cause like you
watched I went to school for this like
when your kid and you watched Jurassic
Park you learn oh cool dinosaurs and
then at least for me when you're an
adult you go back like this is a
terrifying situation the West world is
kind of the same way at first you're
just like oh cool robot cowboy you grew
up and you're like this is horrifying I
agree with you your sentences James I
don't know anything about this I think
Anthony Hopkins is in her or something
what hopefully he's like my daughter she
was taken uh-huh how funny would that be
yeah yeah that's right
have you ever questioned the nature
[ __ ] roll happy man are you real well
if you hotel does it matter
hey you're right my mate no I know that
I'm so excited
whoa
Oh
ah damn I'm excited yeah that looks
really cool yeah you know it does have
kind of that ex machina vibe to it oh
yeah a little bit I think it's really
relevant here yeah you're the laboratory
and the one-on-one you know with I just
think st. a little bit was a little
unfair you know what I mean what about
the whole western half come on I know
I'm saying but there's a total like ex
machina Tony - okay at least that's what
it looks like to me well I really hope
this show does contain because okay
let's talk about what I really like from
the mystery vibe to [ __ ] JJ Abrams
and personal wounds brother yeah I love
westerns first look what that was was
cool about west wall because it was
still a Western like it was a sci-fi
Western and it's like you really do get
the best of both worlds and that clearly
you get all the crazy futuristic injury
but a place that's meant to look like
the real Wild West so it does you know I
just finished the first two seasons from
dusk till dawn and what the first season
does so well and honoring the original
movie is that the first half of the
first season is like getaway series it's
just them trying to get across the
border last half it's a vampire and I
feel like Westbrook kinda does its
everything and that's the thing with all
these shows that I'm like how are they
gonna do this as a TV show I like the
providing like a true horror element
it's like a horror Western you know does
seem really scary and I do want to know
what's going on this seems like a
mystery I could really get involved with
because the West world war briefs
it's not too huge you know and I feel
like a show could really totally expand
upon that really get to know characters
that you're bringing back from the
original movie and then the new
characters too like there's gonna be a
lot of amazing
in this show I feel it with HBO we're
doing it's you that's really exciting
this is one of those rare movie to TV
show adaptations I'm actually on board
with because the concept alone doesn't
bother me at Westworld show the old
burro was an aurora ham yeah dude yeah
oh yeah he kind of like Lee Van Cleave a
little bit like putting in his own Yul
Brynner England Oh totally I feel you on
that one son I'm always curious about
how these shows are gonna progress like
past the first season but I'm sure they
have enough time to think about the
production value on this thing looks
insane and it also looks like you know
might not be overly expensive because
like just shooting in those locations is
like production value enough well I feel
like I could totally expand upon my past
the first season because we're gonna get
a whole set of characters that an HBO
does something really well which is they
have characters in their shows like real
well-thought-out characters most of the
time you got some great actors in here
you know Anthony Hopkins finally in a TV
show it's a cool role yeah it's a really
cool role to do TV isn't there like a
sequel that's a different theme isn't
there in another yeah like future worlds
yeah ascott future world now I'm
wondering like maybe maybe they'll make
like the first season be west room the
second season the future world and then
maybe they'll create a new world for the
third one like do the anthology thing
maybe or maybe though I think they can
just really take their time and Nix and
take moments I see this idea and I'm
like this seems like it has potential to
expand a lot and isn't James Marcin in
it Larson's marcin Mars did Marsden yes
Marsden the s first yeah Mars
oh I would say Mar did sin no oh we saw
ed Harris in there - yeah when Anne
Harris knows how to be a scary
[ __ ] yeah he does he's man in
black apparently and yeah especially in
the Old West man like Ed Harris has that
like facial structure that like chisel
has those eyes that stare yeah
it's kind of like that deal gay yeah
they're like nasty kind of stare and
he's one of those actors who like can be
really endearing and warm and also be
just [ __ ] scary
oh no way Jesus Christ himself from love
I'm excited for that [ __ ] last Stan
Jesus now what oh my god okay that's a
God every time I see Jeffrey right um
show up he's like uh he's like a Gary
Oldman kind of guy yeah he shows up in
these like in like little character
parts
yeah always really good like he's okay
the first movie I ever saw him in was
Angels in America for H oh yeah yeah
this is not funny they have a
relationship already Jeffrey Wright
played two people who we played like a a
really gay guy like just super gay guy
and then like a badass like you know he
has that deep voice yeah why like a
super Jeffrey Wright yeah you played two
very different people and my bottom is
bull that's what's up that's what's up
Jeff Jeff right right there this is
great territory for HBO to go into
sci-fi you know have they never done
sci-fi before something that's like
really science fiction I'm sure they've
done something there but yeah maybe not
as like really this is like super this
is about like an jerk manager was really
cool artificial beans into ologist yeah
HBO has done Western before and now if
they if they can do sci-fi thank you sir
I mean I keep track of cables so they've
never done sci-fi before I think sci-fi
is one of the best genres ever in film
HBO they opened the door for like all
this cable [ __ ] we got today you know
this high production value TV and that's
like you ready r-rated yeah
and they think like the other big ones
like Showtime sci-fi
some of them do again I can't keep track
because main competition is Showtime
because they're the two that can get
away with like full-on badge and like go
or through the roof you know this is
taking too ambitious genres and putting
them together there are a couple Western
shows on cable right now and maybe some
loose sci-fi but like to have them come
together at HBO and to look [ __ ] rad
like that's a I think this trailer is
awesome like I cannot wait to watch the
Brazilian math you know they've got the
production value and they know they got
everything they need so I got well I'm
excited you're excited we're all excited
hey what a good time to end this video
if you're new to my channel and if
you're new to John's channel and if you
need anyone's channel hit that subscribe
button I recommend it John is reasons to
Jerry's right you know the other day I
was like I wish I could listen to videos
which is John and I talked and sure
enough there was reasons to Jerry
primarily John and I follow facebook.com
slash Blum House blue mouse don't leave
home without it don't leave home without
it i recomment I recommend